Hey the first challenge from yoga master
may be not a sub but deserves a game for
the being the first challenge okay good
luck yoga master what to do let's play
let's play the Alekhine I'm gonna mix it
up with openings today maybe I'll keep
my my opening list I'll play d5 hey we
have people in the chat let's play D for
the counter-attack okay things are
already getting weird I'll make things
more dynamic
I mean objectively e tix is probably
better but this looks interesting
open file for the rook but the Queen
here yeah hello to everyone right a
rider first in the chats and g3 is very
reasonable as Bishop g2 coming I'll
start with this and after Bishop g2 I
have this or this InfoSec welcome back
thanks for subbing also thanks to my
opponent for gifting me a knight also I
do have tea delicious the Alaskan hand
mixed tea it's really good
let's take a thing which fork is gonna
happen
the knight wants to fork ooh I don't get
to fork let's play this I'll probably
play this move wait a minute
maybe I could take a pawn let's take a
pawn oh this is so nice I may be losing
a pawn but okay here's a fork
I have queenside castling potential this
is reasonable
I'll play this move play this move Oh
get ready for it get ready for it get
ready for it the castling queenside with
check double attack winning the rook
that's so sweet
that doesn't happen every day man
castling queenside double attack oh the
game okay
now it's just a matter of converting for
those of you who are just joining who
didn't see that that beauty I'll have a
slow-motion replay okay let's sack back
the rook just to simplify and then I
would like to mate without actually
needing to promote so I'm gonna attempt
to control all the squares oh well it
wants to win a pawn okay let's throw in
a check yeah the goal is to do this and
then this and just kind of suffocate the
white King
okay the suffocation is beginning get
ready for it I want to play King c5r
could be to check working on the dark
squares just so the LightSquared Bishop
doesn't have a way of helping out mmm
still takes a bit of work hmm check
check
start with check upon once a draw
maybe later some day I really want to
access this square there we go dah okay
how do I meet let's go this way and then
now this way okay
now the bishop can't really effectively
check me and rook a one coming okay that
was fun that was really fun for those of
you who missed it okay I got a winning
position pretty quickly but yeah I mean
when I played c6 I already had an idea
this was coming his rook b1 and rook
takes b7 so natural hey Brian thanks for
the the sub-vi queenside castling
surprisingly legal it's it's legal for
the rook to move through attack and the
king the King wasn't moving through a
square which was attacked and it won the
exchange so maybe this will go on
YouTube that would be a short YouTube
video okay maybe I'm gonna add let me
let me extend the YouTube video let me
show one more example not only for the
YouTube audience but for the twitch
audience because I have a game just like
a friendly like over the word blitz game
a few years ago which which featured a
really nice idea that this kind of
reminded me of and the game was see if I
can remember it I was black we went into
this this English opening line played
Bishop e6 be 397 g3
and very quickly in the center open dump
and even though this is blitz I had a
very deep calculation starting in this
position actually this position I I was
able to calculate until the end of the
game now it's it's not like a super
forcing line but it is a nice kind of
flowing variation so I'll just go ahead
and show it and starting with Knight
takes c3 and then Queen d5 so relatively
direct attack white saves the rook I
take the pawn I was able to calculate
this because it's so natural like rook B
b1 attempting to win back the pawn and
then here it's a question what should
black do and I've shown this to students
where I tell them to find the best move
for black there's a couple best moves
whether it be Bishop c2 or Bishop a4 in
the game I played Bishop to a4 my
opponent took on and b7 and now for the
YouTube audience and for the twitch
audience black to move and find the
winning move and it should be simple
given what we just saw but yeah let's
see who in the chat is first hey we have
a minute finding the very powerful again
queenside castling this time it's not
checked but it's made threats so it was
important to keep the bishop controlling
d1 and my opponent just resigned because
whites losing a whole rook so i actually
showed this in a st. louis chess club in
youtube or yeah st. louis chess club
youtube video slash lecture many years
ago but i don't think i've shown this on
my youtube channel so there you go
people on youtube hope you enjoy that
twitch chat hope you enjoyed that people
on youtube i'll see you in the future